Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér. Dr. Papers.
Today we are going to look at an incredible
way to supercharge Stable Diffusion,
which is a free an open text to image
AI. Text goes in, beautiful images come
out. We all know that. However, this
is ControlNet, a new neural network
structure that helps us give it additional
inputs. What does that mean? More control.
For instance, we can provide just the edges
of an input image. This can be a rough sketch,
or edges extracted from a real photo,
and bam, we get a beautiful image with
exactly that creature and framing.
Wow, that is exactly what I want!
We can also provide this thing
that we call a boundary map,
and ControlNet is able to follow that too.
Do you know what else also works?
Segmentation maps. This is just
a rough draft of where different
objects should be, and my goodness,
out comes a beautiful piece of landscape
and architecture, or even an interior. And
just look at that. All this came from these
really coarse, poor images. And don’t forget,
this works both ways, so we can even give
the AI a photo, ask for the segmentation map,
and then add a prompt to make it a
painting, remove a tree or anything else.
Pose works too. A stickman goes in,
and a photorealistic image
comes out. That is incredible.
So, what else can we do with ControlNet? Well,
after looking at these 4 amazing
examples that I am about to show you,
by the end of this video, you will see
that a more appropriate question would
be what can’t we do with it. I will also tell
you whether you can try it or not in a moment.
Now hold on to your papers Fellow Scholars,
because this is going to be insane. One,
with ControlNet, we can even transform ourselves.
In goes a dancing video of us, and out comes this.
Is this really happening? I cannot
believe this. Just look at how good
the temporal coherence is! Yes, there are
some unexpected changes from image to image,
a little flickering, but this is improving
so fast, two more papers down the line,
I bet my papers that no one is going to
be able to tell. Just imagine how artists,
and even non-artists will be able to unleash their
creativity with this. Don’t have an expensive
camera to record this? Not a problem. No access to
expensive lighting equipment? Not a problem. Heck,
you don’t even need to be at the location,
it can be synthesized! This is incredible.
Two, we can even create a group photo,
and we can all enter a virtual world
where we can be recreated with the
same pose, character by character.
How cool is that? So this was cartooning.
And, are you thinking what I am thinking?
Oh yes, three, decartooning
is also possible. This way,
we can make cartoons and even our own drawn
characters come to life. I really like how
the skirt has been reimagined in a way that
it could really exist in the real world.
Four, Weights and Biases also asked the AI to
reimagine their logo. And it did not disappoint.
Some of these are really imaginative. And wait,
this is not just style transfer. Look at this
animation example where the original real
footage is used as a control signal. First,
these indeed look like style transfer into
a watercolor or oil painting, but now,
look! It can truly reimagine the footage. Amazing!
And the best part about ControlNet
is whenever I am working with a tool
like this I feel more satisfied, and more
strongly involved in the creative process.
I am not just prompting, I feel like I
am at least partly creating something.
I also feel like people are sleeping on this
paper. They don’t yet know that the world of
digital art as we know it will change very
quickly. More of us will have access to these
fantastic tools that we could never afford
to. And now it is available for all of us,
for free! The possibilities truly
make my head spin. And this is just
one paper. And this is a technique
that is free and open to everyone,
we build this together, so you Fellow Scholars
are all welcome to contribute prompts, code,
experiments, anything. This gives power to
the people for free, that's what I want. Yes,
I put a link to it in the video description
and to a guide too, so you can try it for free.
And one more interesting tidbit from the paper
- this neural network can even work with smaller
datasets, so if we have less than 50 thousand
images, that is completely fine, wow, but it
can scale to billions of images if we so desire.
A big thanks for the Stable Diffusion subreddit
as they host a ton of amazing artistic works with
ControlNet. And now, let the experiments begin!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!